hey everyone developer here and well i can't
lie to you i'm still left in like absolute
shock after what happened throughout this arc
it's like trying to physically hold myself
back from continuing past the 40th chapter
which i've completely and utterly failed in
but moving on this arc here is the fourth
installment in tatsuki fujimoto's story
and like the main character denji we finally come
face to face with another half devil human hybrid
which results in some truly heroising moments the
battles in the story all multiply in its intensity
and it really starts giving us a true insight
into how broken our souls will be by the time
that we actually finish the series so grab some
melons and sit back as we go over the one and only
katana man arc of chainsaw man as per usual
though all your lovely humans make sure you
grab a baseball bear and start backheely bassing
up that like button for me plus if you are new
around here and want to watch more anime explain
content just like this then make sure to follow
through with that bat on the subscribe button but
anyway enough of that let's get into chainsaw man
while in a ramen shop denji himeno aki and power
all eat meanwhile various 4th division agents from
the previous night's drinking attend to their
duties in various locations throughout the city
as they do all the civilians around them pull
out guns and gun shots are heard ringing out
the group inside the ramen shop hears the gunshots
but they assume that they're merely drum beats a
stranger on the table next to them then speaks up
insulting the quality of the ramen dingy and power
are both offended by this and their man comments
on their peers unrefined palette remarking that
those who do not eat much in their youth gain a
poor sense of taste sensing something wrong aki
asks to leave the man continues though discussing
his beloved grandfather whom would often spoil
him he then reveals his grandfather to be the
old man who was possessed by the zombie devil
he accuses denji of the old man's death before
stating the gun devil wants your heart he pulls
out a gun and shoots dingy in the head before
shooting himino in the chest and arky in the arm
before he can continue though power punches him
knocking the gun out of his hand aki then summons
the fox devil to devour the man he then worriedly
looks at dingy's unmoving body as well as amino's
critically injured state the fox devil then
suddenly informs him that the man was neither
human nor devil before it is torn apart from the
inside the man re-emerges revealing himself to be
a devil-human hybrid fused with the katana devil
aki orders power to stop hamino's bleeding as he
pulls out his sword aki unleashes his sword and
power is surprised to see that it resembles a nail
rather than a blade katana man starts swinging
atom but aki dodges before reading in his blade
as he shouts fire an off-panel devil is shown
flicking the nails point into the katana man
a disembodied mouth is then seen sounding their
number three katana man hesitates before swinging
again aki once again dodges shouting fire once
more and passing the katana men again again the
disembodied voice speaks saying the number two
aki makes a final lunge passing the katana man's
belly and the voice states one the katana man
knocks aki back showing confusion over aki's plan
aki however calls the devil out to finish him
revealing it to be the cursed devil as the devil
states zero and massive disembodied hand is shown
to grab the katana man he briefly expresses shock
before being torn limb from limb by the giant
skeletal devil he falls to the floor unconscious
and bleeding profusely aki calls out to power
who recommends getting hamino a doctor aki is
shocked by the use of a gun in the man's ominous
statement regarding the gun devil suddenly a young
woman appears commenting on the cursed devil's
power as aki asks whether she is working with a
katana man she steps forward and picks him back
up the girl named sawatari asks the katana man
why he lost torchy ashamedly responds he let down
his guard she orders him to kill the group quickly
leading the katana man to lunge forward at aki
before he can respond his chest is suddenly
slashed by the katanas aki heavily injured by
the attack falls to the floor sawatari comments
on how the wounds are likely non-fatal due to the
devil hunter's suits being reinforced hemino tells
power to forget her and help aki however power
refuses believing herself to be far outmatched
hemino attempts to summon the ghost devil but it
refuses out of fear of sarwatari as a last resort
to save aki himuno offers her everything to the
ghost devil the devil's grimace quickly turns to a
smile as its true giant form is revealed the ghost
devil attacks the katana man with each attack
hemino loses more of her body as she does this she
thinks about aki and remarks on how unusual it is
that he was still able to cry as most devil
hunters grow emotionally stunted over time as aki
looks at her she tells him not to die as she wants
someone to be able to cry over her death sawatari
summons the snake devil ordering it to devour the
ghost devil it does leaving nothing left of amino
aside from her clothes sawatari and the katana
man turn to dingy stating that their goal is to
take his heart as they say this the ghost devil's
dying hand is seen floating towards dingy's body
it pulls the cord on his chest reawakening
and transforming him into his chainsaw form
though he is confused by the current situation
he instantly recognizes the katana man and
sarwatari as enemies excitedly charging at them
stating that he loves bad guys as no one cares
how he brutally kills them salwatari noting
she is missing fingernails calls for backup
over a walkie-talkie she looks at aki who was in
shock over himino's fate denji and the katana man
continue fighting with the katana man showing the
ability to slash large areas with a single strike
two backup agents arrive firing guns at denji
though he is shot he is able to knock both down
and takes one as a hostage angrily the katana man
slices through both of them cutting them in half
at a speed denji was unable to register picking up
dingy's top half the katana man orders the other
agents to get to a car remarking that the other
members of the fourth division are likely dead
due to the human vulnerability to guns the scene
cuts showing the corpses of awry fushi hamino
makima and the two other hunters who were at
the drinking party in makima's train carriage
the assassins plan to blend in with the civilians
however they are interrupted by makima standing
up who was somehow miraculously survived at the
station two hunters cross and tendo wait they
are shocked to hear news of makima's death before
seeing her step out of the train in front of them
makima informs them of the attack as they
remark on these similar attacks in tokyo
they note their blood on her clothes but she tells
them that she was not hit during the gun fight as
she dodged every bullet inside the train we
find the bodies of the train assassins each
of them with gaping holes in their chests moving
forward makima theorizes that the gun agents are
going after denji she orders kuros nintendo
to find her a shrine with a high elevation
and 30 criminals with life sentences as well as a
change of clothes elsewhere the gun agents begin
to move dingy's top half into a car as they do
one begins to sweat remarking how strange he feels
in an instant he is flattened by an invisible
force horrifying his compatriots panicked sabatari
calls the team e asking them to confirm makima's
death with c team and a team agent responds
commenting that they've lost contact with sea
team however he is too flattened mid-sentence
elsewhere at the shrine makima enacts a ritual
tendo and kuros as well as 30 prisoners are
blindfolded tendu informs corrose that due to
her high ranking the nature of the devil magima
has a contract with is kept classified makima
orders a prisoner to say the name mishima shuzo
he complies the gun agent named mishima shuzo is
instantly flattened afterwards the prisoner then
falls dead as makima instructs the next prisoner
to say another name and so on and so on throughout
the entire country multiple gun agents are
constantly flattened suddenly makima stops making
it instructs carouse entendo to take off their
blindfolds telling them that she has done all she
can do from their current location panicked to the
situation and people dying around her sarwatari
orders the katana man to move denji before makima
can interfere further as he does he suddenly sees
a figure moving towards them which is kabini
clutching a knife a flashback shows they whilst
on duty together arai was shot by an elderly
gun agent in his last moments he threw himself
in front of kabini shielding her from being killed
as well kavini asks sawatari and the katarda man
whether they are gun agents and unnerved sabotage
summons the snake devil's tail to attack her
she swiftly dodges it though before running along
its body towards the pier before the katana man
could shoot at her she deftly slices his arm
off grabs the gun and shoots him in the back
she then turns her aim to sabotari sabotari fires
at her but she uses dingies reinforced chains
her head to deflect the bullet samutari grabs the
katana man and drags him into the car driving away
kumini looks down at denji's unconscious torso and
apologizes for trying to kill him in the past she
slowly begins to laugh growing slowly hysterical
as she remembers a rise dead body before deciding
she plans to tell hermino that she quits at
a similar time arriving in tokyo makima is
greeted by madoka he informs her that almost every
agent in divisions one through four were killed
he states that the orders from the top of the
organizations and that all divisions will be
merged and placed under mahima's control
the news causes her to smile calmly madoka
anticipating a coming conflict quits on the
spot as he leaves he asks makima one more thing
how much of the events she had anticipated but
she merely responds that she is unable to share
classified details with a civilian awakening in
a hospital bed aki turns to see denji and power
at his bedside reading manga and arguing over
airpoles aki asks who of the fourth division
survived was dingy responding that only kabini
and madoka made it but madoka had instantly quit
dingy and power then turned to leave as they
were summoned by makima however noting aki's
quiet despondence dingy leaves him an apple now
alone in his room aki and sheesh the cursed sword
and asks the cursed devil how long he has to
live it responds that he is two years aki then
picks up a cigarette however remembering himeno he
drops it and breaks down crying outside the room
denji looks through the window hoping to collect
the manga that he had left in there he begins to
walk away before suddenly realizing that despite
his attachment to himino her death has not caused
her to cry or feel any real sadness he thinks back
to the sadness he felt after pochita's death and
realizes that neither power nor aki's death would
make him cry he thinks that even if mahima were to
die though he would be depressed for a short while
he would get over it surprisingly quick troubled
by these thoughts he wonders if giving his heart
to a devil truly robbed him of his humanity
resolving not to think about such depressing
topics he and power leave to meet with makima
as they do tendo and carose enter aki's room to
instruct him regarding the changes to the fourth
division meanwhile makima explains the denji and
power that the bureau believes enemy forces are
targeting denji specifically as such they have
prepared a training course for the two of them
she begins to introduce them to kishibe but
is interrupted by him he asks them of their
thoughts when their comrades died to which they
state that they pretty much felt nothing he then
asks them of their desire for revenge which they
both re-buff lastly he asks them whether they're
loyal to humans or devils to which they both
respond whomever will give them their best deal
hearing this kishibe expresses a satisfaction with
their responses he steps forward and puts his arms
around denji and powell's shoulders stating that
their training has started makima turns to leave
eskashibe explains that he is a devil
hunter working with a special first division
and asks that they call him master he then informs
the pair that he enjoys booze woman and killing
devils before he begins to calmly choke the two
of them then snap their necks kashibe drops power
and genji to the floor explaining that their
basic body structures are identical to humans
and as such he snapped their necks paralyzing
them he then gives them blood explaining that
unlike humans it is all they need to recover
from most of their injuries kishibe explains
that he is the strongest devil hunter and as such
he believes that in order to train the two of them
they need to reach a point where they can beat him
in a confrontation deji and power move towards him
preparing to fight however khasheba swiftly stabs
denji in the head and back before slicing powell's
throat he comments on the inhuman intuition to
try and attack him without a moment of hesitation
he states that since he was a child he
always hoped for a toy that wouldn't break
before promising to turn the pair into the
baddest of the badasses meanwhile in his
hospital beard aki is surprised to find he is
unable to summon khan kuros remarks that the
devil is likely angry for being killed and as such
likely to never respond to him again tendu asks of
aki's lifespan after using the cursed devil but he
interrupts and asks of their intentions with him
they reveal that due to the worsening of the devil
crisis and massive losses to the organization
the bureau intended to request he makes a deal the
massively powerful devil to help gain an advantage
they then give him the choice to quit and live in
a more peaceful life however he refuses seeking
revenge against the gun devil for killing his
family and the gun agents for killing himino
as kuros and tendo leave an unseen woman
enters surprising haki that night kishiba
decides to stop the training so that he can go
home and sleep dingy collapses from exhaustion
as power gives him some of her blood to heal him
the pair walk home bloodied and tattered power
comments on how dingy likely died 20 times and she
was knocked unconscious the same amount the two
consider running away with zinji noticing that
fighting without enjoying himself is the worst
suddenly power suggests that rather than using
brute force they try and outsmart khasheba causing
the pair to grow excited and remark that they
feel smarter already kishibi walks towards denji
and power's apartment annoyed at them for being
late to training from inside power smells his
presence as the pair now wearing glasses moved to
put this super genius strategy into action power
thrusts a sphere of blood through the door however
kishibe intuitively dodges it on the floor above
the parrot place bottles of blood which power
uses to spare through the ceiling above koshibay
again koshibe blocks and dodges them however denji
drops down behind him quietly hoping to hit him
with an axe however kishibe swiftly kicks him in
the head knocking him down without even looking
kishibe commends them for their attempt stating
it was their best yet but points out that the pair
were weakened by power's massive loss of blood and
dingy's inability to predict attacks he tells them
that they're done for the day however as
denji begins to relax he flings a knife at him
one in the duo that pray shouldn't trust
what a hunter says meanwhile kuros and tendo
take aki to the bureau's devil holding facility
they remind him that making a contract with these
devils will entail heavy losses however it will
ultimately protect him and they come in conflicts
cross asks about the girl who visited him in
the hospital to which aki reveals that she was
hermino's younger sister she gave him a number
of letters hamina had written over the years
many of which discussed him in one highlighted
passage though we see that ximena had asked is
there anything that i can do to get aki to quit
which is something that shakes him to his core
as they reach a chamber carrots reveals that they
intend for aki to make a contract with a future
devil they remark on two previous agents who made
a contract with it one who gave up half of their
lifespan and the other who gave up both of their
eyes as well as their sense of taste and smell
aki then enters the room and sees a humanoid
tree-like future devil emerged from the shadows
as it repeats the phrase constantly the future
is best the future devil repeats phrases such as
the future rules and requests that argue repeat
them as well aki states his intention of making
a contract annoying the devil the devil requests
to read are his future by placing his head in
his chest cavity as he complies the devil begins
giggling profusely and agrees to the contract on
the condition that he can live in his right eye
aki is shocked by the easiness of the request
however the devil mockingly informs him that it
wants to see his future with its own eyes as he
will die in the worst way possible it asks if
he wants to know how he will die however aki
refuses before agreeing to the contract unfazed
at all meanwhile dingy and power lay beeson on
a floor kishibe comments on their improvements
and informs them that their training will become
weekly instead of daily he wants them to keep a
cool head and remain aware of their surroundings
before informing them that their new fourth
division will be hunting sawatari and the katana
man khashebi informs them that if the mission
fails the fourth division will be shut down
and he'll be forced to kill them denji heavily
remarks though that if they were to fight he'd
spare kishibe as thanks for making him stronger
and moving him closer to the goal of deity makima
later kashubi sits down to drink with makima he
remarks his unhappiness with a continuing dingy
and powers training due to his growing attachment
towards them he then questions mahima on his
pre-existing knowledge of the attacks remarking
that as long as she's on humanity's side he'll
look the other way maki mistakes her goal
as being to save as many people as possible
and increase the prestige of the fourth division
kishibe considers this before calling her a liar
makima smiles eerily in response in an office
building the gun agents reconvene planning to
put their leader into hiding salwatari points out
the pointlessness of hiding giving mahima's power
hearing this the katana man agrees intending to
kill denji with his own hands so atari reveals
the group's ultimate weapon a cluster of zombies
left over by the zombie devil elsewhere in a car
as they drive aki back home kuros asks him of
his intention to kill the gun devil he states
his annoyance commencing on the ridiculous notion
that a normal person like aki could make any kind
of impact aki responds though that whilst the goal
is unrealistic he requires an unrealistic outlook
to make progress crows tosses mikola saying that
though such an outlook irritates him he'll still
support it meanwhile makima meets with a yakuza
boss he explains that though the gun agents are
members of his organization he does not condone
their actions he elaborates that the factions
were influenced by sawatari who had had them make
small deals with the gun devil paying money for
guns and ammunition magma requests the names of
every yakuza member who contacted the gun devil
both within the bosses group and his rivals
however the boss refuses explaining that such
a betrayal would cause all-out gang warfare
resulting in foreign mafias invading japan
he then calls the devil hunters idiots without
any real education causing his compatriots to
laugh at makima makimedo places a small bag on
the table she explains as the man looks within it
that the eyeballs are from all of the family
members of every person in this room as a boss
looks in horror makima offers to return them
to their owners in return for his cooperation
a yakuza grunt swings at her however he
immediately collapses with blood pouring
from his face meanwhile the special forces of the
bureau prepared to storm the gun agent's building
inside salwatari talks to the katana man
reaffirming their plan to kill as many
devil hunters as possible and steal denji's
heart kishibe orders the hunters to storm the
building as a pack of zombies lion weight below
them koshiba introduces himself to the second
division leader firono and police officer sheena
who are in charge of locking down the building
he gives a rundown of the various non-human
members of the special fourth division
inside the building the shark thing beam
appears and begins devouring these zombies
in his frenzy he accidentally bites the violence
fiend who knocks him down before apologizing
attacking more zombies the violence fiend notices
a woman nearby and warns her to stay away before
realizing that she is also a devil and is in fact
the spider devil she stands up and decapitates
a zombie whose head falls at the feet of the
angel devil who begins eating away at the bodies
aki appears and begins cutting through the zombies
the angel devil asks saki for a hanky chief to
clean up some blood before explaining to him that
he absorbs others lifespans through touch and is
surprised at how close aki has got him a gunman
suddenly appears and tries shooting at the two but
the angel deflects the bullet and aki stabs him
aki continues on his own eventually coming face
to face with sawatari she uses her stake devil to
release the ghost devil which is now subservant to
her aki moves forward deflecting most of the ghost
devil's attacks for the future devil's future side
however he is quickly overwhelmed by the many arms
of the ghost devil and is soon being strangled by
the creature in a flashback he remembers an early
meeting with hamino and which she offered him
a cigarette however once she realizes that
he's underage she takes it back and promises
him to give it back to him when he really
needs to rely on something in the present
aki looks up having been released from the ghost
devil's grasp from amongst its mass hamino's right
arm reaches out holding a cigarette taking it
ahi sees the words easy revenge written across it
taking a deep breath he steps forward remembering
hermino's revise he reflects that the ghost devil
is blind and senses its surroundings based on fear
remaining calm aki climbs a topic before promising
himino that he'll die soon then he decapitates the
ghost devil a shock sabotary moves to summon the
snake devil but is stopped like a beanie holding
a knife to her throat aki orders kabini not to
kill her he then asks kabini why she didn't quit
the bureau to which she awkwardly responds that
she was close to earning her bonus dingy and power
then arrive in the headquarters using an elevator
power begins chomping on a severed zombified hand
disgusting dingy and causing the two to scuffle
as they argue the elevator doors open revealing
a swarm of zombies in front of them due to the
zombies not noticing them dingy recommends they
stay quiet and utilize the element of surprise
power however begins yelling loudly challenging
the zombies to combat power bravely steps forward
and begins fighting as a bewildered and annoyed
denji remains in the elevator believing denji
is still watching her power easily slashes away
through dozens of hulking zombies boasting that
she is the strongest there is as denji's elevator
arrives on the highest floor he prepares to pull
his chainsaw's cord the door opens and he sees
the katana man alongside a pair of gun agents
the katana man asks him to pause so we can ask
a few questions he explains the group's desire
for compensation over the old man's death with
denji frustratedly explaining that the old man
was zombified when the devil killed him however he
doesn't believe this instead the katana man asks
denji whether he truly felt nothing when killing
the zombies reminding him that they used to be
humans denji though repeats that he felt nothing
the katana man then reveals that despite giving
his heart to a devil unlike denji he still feels
guilt over killing zombies explaining that dingy
is the only devil human hybrid without a sense of
conscience he requests dingy to accept his death
as a form of mercy killing but denji casually
responds that he doesn't wanna and an irritated
katana man takes off his hand and becomes to
transform in front of him the two now transformed
crash through a wall and begin falling towards
the streets below the katana men and denji still
in combat continue falling as denji is pushed away
he falls and lands atop a moving train readjusting
he is able to block an attack from the still
falling katana man which sends them crashing
into a crowded carriage as floods of passengers
flee a voice over announces the train is coming
to an emergency stop denji notices a remaining
passenger an injured woman lying on the floor
as the katana man launches an attack denji
blocks her protecting the woman but losing
his arm in the process the woman runs away as then
she angrily shout that they should ban their move
the katana man then attacks again slicing
off denji's other arm he then demands that
as long as denji can no longer fight he should
apologize for killing the old man and accept death
however denji refuses stating that as long as he
has his chainsaw on his head he can still fight
the two clash again however the impact causes
the blade on denji's chainsaw head to shatter
the katana man again demands an apology in
return for a swift death but this time denji
reveals that the katana man was so distracted with
anger that he didn't notice being sliced in half
by denji's leg the katana man now revealed
to have been split vertically reacts with a
moment of surprise before his body completely
falls apart into a mass of blood and organs
watching then she repeats the words told to him by
kishibe pray should never trust what a hunter says
a little while later and now outside the stopped
train the katana man now reverted to human form
and wearing nothing but underwear awakens next
to the train bound by a set of chains or blades
a shirtless denji stands over him expressing his
surprise over his speedy recovery an infuriated
katana man threatens to kill him but denji rebuffs
it calling him a loser dingy states that he is
waiting for the police to come and arrest him
however he notes that he is unwilling to accept
the katana man merely facing imprisonment
after being responsible for himino's death
as aki arrives then she announces he's planning a
tournament as revenge deji asks saki if he'd like
to join in on the tournament stating that he shot
himino so his punishment should be nut shots he
then reveals the rules of his tournament taking it
in turns to kick the katana man in his testicles
with whomever can make him scream the loudest
before the police arrive being crowned the winner
loudly sighing aki states it's not their job
to torture him and himino would be unhappy with
such actions however after looking at the
cigarette he was given by the ghost devil
he rolls up his sleeves and asks about the reward
for the winner dingy responds and they get to keep
the remains of his testicles somewhere across the
city the remaining gun agents are rounded up while
the angel devil looks into the distance the scene
returns to the katana man screaming in pain as aki
and denji excitedly beat into him as he kicks him
aki thinks of himino stating that his screams of
pain are their requiem for her elsewhere makima
reports the events of the date of the bureau
they question why the gun agents desired
denji's heart but makima reveals that
the snake devil killed salwatari before she
could be questioned likely as a part of their
contract makima reveals though that with the gun
devil's fragments they've collected from the gun
agents they have a mass large enough to begin
indicating the location of the gun devil that
night dingy has a dream of standing in front of
a door he notes that the dream is reoccurring
from the other side an eye looks in as pachita's
voice repeats his name happily denji asks pachita
to enter so he can pet him however vegeta
ominously tells him to never open this door
denji then awakens in a cold sweat he looks over
and sees aki and power napping beside him power
is reawakened by dingy shouts setting up and
revealing that she has grown several new horns
commenting on them power responds by punching him
the knock is powerful enough to send him flying
across the room and surprise the both of them
later on while observing power's new enlarged
horns makima informs dingy that she has ingested
too much blood from the zombies and requires some
to be drained in order to decrease her strength to
make her less unruly dingy agrees causing power to
nervously sweat makima reveals that walt's power
is busy he has been partnered with a shark fiend
called beam beam then suddenly appears from the
floor attempting to hug dingy but a surprise dingy
knocks him down mucky mistakes that beam has a
distinct fondness for dingy and has promised to
follow any of his orders noting dingy is in a bad
mood makima invites him out on a date the next day
denji excitedly waits for her to arrive arriving
several hours early makima also shows up early
and reveals that the pair are going to
have a movie marathon at a local cinema
non-stop until midnight during the first film
then she notes that he isn't laughing with the
rest of the audience looking at makima
he sees that she is not laughing either
after the film makima briefly critiques her
commenting on the plot and cinematography
the pair attend the next film and dingy again
notices that he and makima are the only ones not
reacting to the film again as the film ends makima
critiques it the cycle continues throughout the
day with dingy growing continuously bored before
they enter the final film denji comments that none
of the films had any impacts on him comey seen
that he may just not really get films making
responds that she is the same however the very
few that she did react to changed her life as
they view their next film then she is shocked to
find himself crying at a seemingly trivial scene
looking at makima he sees she is also silently
crying the two then leave the cinema and good
spirits talking about how they enjoyed the last
film then she questions makima as to whether she
believes he has a heart and in response she leans
in and listens to his heartbeat before telling him
that he certainly does she smiles and walks away
leaving dingy blushing in the middle of the street
well i guess that brings us to the end of
part 4 of tatsuki fujimoto's chainsaw man
obviously this part of the story has like
completely and utterly exploded and just death and
destruction and what the [__] is actually going
on right now where is himino man like she just
disappeared like i don't even know what to kind
of take from the entire situation i'm in the same
state aki was just crying in a crying out a bed
the whole time like the whole time this is exactly
how i'm feeling right now after this like what's
making my how how she dodged all of these bullets
on the train like i'm trying to understand right
now what in the world is going on so i can't wait
to finally get into this next start if you guys
can hear there's a chainsaw in the background
so you know i thought i thought it'd be different
come outside and everything but some [__] kids
decided to in the middle of nowhere start using
his chainsaw to cut down trees near a river but i
you know i guess i can't do too much about that i
hope you guys have enjoyed the video obviously uh
it's taken me a little bit longer to put this
one together than i would have liked which is
probably going to be the case with the next up
and coming arcs as well as they just gradually
get longer uh these last three arcs here so i'm
super excited to finally be able to read the
bomb girl or bomb devil arc now um as far as
i know i think a [__] possum just ran down
a tree over there i heard something i'd honestly
there's so much noise out here i really thought
it was going to be quiet and real peaceful and
we could chill out and i could do my outro here
and stuff but it's kind of just kind of but anyway
if you guys have enjoyed the video make sure you
leave a like on it and if you are new around here
make sure you also hit that subscribe button as it
really helps out with pushing my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people but anyway enough of that
for now it's been your professional degenerate
dear volo and i will see you all in april bye
you